[Music]
I got three different Brandon things
I don't know which one to do first
because it's been a cornucopia with him
but I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give
you well actually let's say two it's two
burning things sorry I'm gonna give you
tell me one of them is a video of
Brendan Schwab trying to pronounce
Cornucopia no but
if you can't do that
um but I have hear me out hear me out I
have Dave Rubin on the fighter and the
kid
or I have Brendan doing crowd work
all right I'd second that I don't I
understand why you made that decision
I've I respect it here let me pull it up
give me a second here
all right uh let's see window
what the [ __ ]
I hope this isn't one of those monkey
paw things MERS for [ __ ] he yeah we
skipped out on Dave Rubin but Tom
McDonald in the audience I think that's
just to crowd work with
okay so back quick background this was
he was in Baltimore
or Baltimore as you would call it this
is Brendan that's not Brendan that's a
black guy oh I was like why is he shaped
like Bray Wyatt oh I don't know but um
this is um them at Baltimore this is on
Brendan chops his own YouTube channel so
this is where I'm getting it from so
he's the one that edited or whoever
we're probably big gay lion and editor
for him and
um the title of this uh Baltimore is a
fighting town
okay
I don't want to hear [ __ ] you got to say
for the rest of the night hey [ __ ] tell
me what that [ __ ] thinking that's
another comic
story
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it was Dick and twisted grab his dick
and twist it oh my god dude wait
[Music]
I know when you go to Brandon shows
because somebody told me that they went
to one
they don't they did I'm being serious
somebody went on was it on the record or
off the record I can't say who went
that's the show is off the road but some
people off the record I went away and
let's just say they weren't going with
good intentions can I say that because I
don't want to ruin it to try it again
so they weren't going with good
intentions but you know Brennan has a
rule now
like Dave Chappelle would for example
where you can't have a phone you have to
put the you have to give your phone out
because he's afraid of his shitty set
getting leaked the only whenever you see
a video of Brandon being it's his own
people filming so yeah it's pretty gay
line or something that way they could
control the stuff that goes out and you
don't see all his bombing just so you
know and it's obvious because it's on
the side of the stage yeah
what's that day like you've ever seen
roll with the dicks by the way the dick
thing
remember that we said that that picture
that he said that was The Joe Rogan joke
someone pointed out to us the the whole
like you know uh the gay guy likes to
whatever that was those Joe Rogan joke
people get by the way people gave your
credit in the clip uh for pointing out
that it was bothering them and it was
definitely Will Sasso that he was
ripping off somebody even somebody said
in the comment like it was bothering me
I knew he ripped somebody off but I
didn't know like thank you Merc for
wolf's ass
the minute he started doing this yeah I
was like that Will Sasso does that
and I only remember because that that
clip is Iconic you're gonna do some of
that box
I don't know
I'm gonna twist that dick like you've
never seen every time I try to ignore it
hey big gay lion I know you're probably
doing this on your garage man or [ __ ]
whatever Apple edit Apple movie turn the
music down a little bit yeah seriously
dude take some time in between over
enunciating and being a weirdo and
wearing clothes that don't fit come on
you only have to take your trip how to
mix you need to take your trench shot
twice a week you have a lot of free time
in between that Jersey
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
wow he's so he he had a lot of time to
think of something funny and he just
said what
the [ __ ] is happening here bro I'm sorry
but I have seen Steve hofstetter destroy
some planted hecklers and that's not how
you do it
imagine your entire image being
destroying hecklers
that's so sad just be funny stand-up guy
[Applause]
all right you ready for crowd work here
it comes here here you go ready here we
go
[Applause]
appreciate man
yeah I really appreciate it thank you
for not twisting this day
your friend is [ __ ] Shaquille O'Neal
but Whiteface
in Whiteface not butt white face but but
oh my God he even tight butt white face
look when come back
in white face in white face close enough
holy [ __ ]
you could have held it down while he
twisted his death
this Twisted dick thing is not funny
right guys like he's really he's really
milking a twisted dick thing too much
yeah it's it was some guy yelled
something in the crowd that was that's
it
also this is just Brendan we're really
energetic and just repeatedly describing
what's going on
well it was a fight it was crazy dude
it's nuts
it just popped off
Brennan Schaub is like the end of the
line of every La comedian telling jokes
but through the telephone game
and by a Time against sir Brennan it
sounds like this
are we back check we should be back
I mean let me uh refresh here let's
check it out red fresh you homos let's
check it out
I I don't think so
are you sure
yeah it's back actually I just got it
late okay we're back boom sorry guys
ah anyway
I don't know what the [ __ ] that was
about but we're back it was a little
fart little tiny fart then pixels is
coming afterwards that big bent pixels
is coming after us anyway crowd work
back to crowd work coming to Twisted
dick Brandon is so shitty it took it
took the [ __ ] stream down
Twisters dick twisters
like Brennan's terrible bits making them
into Good t-shirts and then selling them
that's the ultimate [ __ ] you printed but
like I said I'm I'm at least he's I'm
really bummed that he's not doing his
patent Bane impression he's really good
at it you know
[Applause]
if you guys want to sit down bring your
friend back please sit down please
[Music]
see he is a nice guy he's such a nice
guy
yeah it's like the people that you know
risk going to jail for him yeah
stop pretending like you're tough
because you're from a city
I hate people you're wearing a thick Boy
shirt oh God hey my city [ __ ] so like
I'm cool and [ __ ] I love that like pride
and how shitty your town is
hey we got a lot of crime and heroin
people beating each other up around here
sounds terrible hey I'm tough I got we
got high property crimes around here